can you summarize the main points in the
blog post AGI ruin a list of lethalities
things that jump to your mind because
um it's a set of thoughts you have about
reasons why AI is likely to kill all of
us
so I I guess I could but I would offer
to instead say like
drop that empathy with me I bet you
don't believe that
why don't you tell me about how why you
believe that AGI is not going to kill
everyone
and then I can like try to describe how
my theoretical perspective differs from
that
who was so well that means I have to uh
the word you don't like the stima and
the perspective that is not going to
kill us I think that's a matter of
probabilities maybe I was mistaken what
what do you believe
just just like forget like the the
debate and and the like dualism and just
like like what do you believe what would
you actually believe what are the
probabilities even I think this probably
is hard for me to think about
really hard
I kind of think in the
in the number of trajectories
I don't know what probability the
scientist trajectory but I'm just
looking at all possible trajectories
that happen and I tend to think that
there is more trajectories that lead to
a a positive outcome than a negative one
that said the negative ones
at least some of the negative ones are
that lead to the destruction of the
human species
and its replacement by nothing
interesting not worthwhile even from
very Cosmopolitan perspective on what
counts as worthwhile yes so both are
interesting to me to investigate which
is humans being replaced by interesting
AI systems and not interesting air
systems both are a little bit terrifying
but yes the worst one is the paperclip
maximizer something totally boring
but to me the positive
and we can we can talk about trying to
make the case of what the positive
trajectories look like
I just would love to hear your intuition
of what the negative is so at the core
of your belief that
uh maybe you can correct me
that AI is going to kill all of us is
that the alignment problem is really
difficult
I mean
in in the form we're facing it
so usually in science if you're mistaken
you run the experiment it shows a result
different from what you expected you're
like oops
and then you like try a different theory
that one also doesn't work and you say
oops
and at the end of this process
which may take decades or and you know
sometimes faster than that
you now have some idea of what you're
doing
AI itself went through this long process
of um
people thought it was going to be easier
than it was
there's a
famous statement that I am somewhat
inclined to like pull out my phone and
try to read off exactly you can by the
way all right oh
oh yes we propose that a two-month
10-man study of artificial intelligence
be carried out during the summer of 1956
at Dartmouth College in Hanover New
Hampshire
the study is to proceed on the basis of
the conjecture that every aspect of
learning or any other feature of
intelligence can in principle be so
precisely described the machine can be
made to simulate it an attempt will be
made to find out how to make machines
use language form abstractions and
Concepts solve kinds of problems now
reserved for humans and improve
themselves we think that a significant
Advance can be made in one or more of
these problems if a carefully selected
group of scientists work on it together
for a summer
and in their report uh summarizing some
of the major
sub-fields of artificial intelligence
that are still worked on to this day
and there's similarly the store the
story which I'm not sure at the moment
is apocryphalonaut of that the uh
gratitude and who got assigned to solve
computer vision over the summer
uh I mean computer vision in particular
is very interesting how little
uh how little we respected the
complexity of vision
so 60 years later
um where you know making progress on a
bunch of that thankfully not yet improve
themselves
um but it took a whole lot of time and
all the stuff that people initially
tried with bright eyed hopefulness did
not work the first time they tried it or
the second time or the third time or the
tenth time or 20 years later
and the and the researchers became old
and grizzled and cynical veterans who
would tell the next crop of bright-eyed
chillflow grad students
artificial intelligence is harder than
you think
and if alignment plays out the same way
the the problem is that we do not get 50
years to try and try again and observe
that we were wrong and come up with a
different Theory and realize that the
entire thing is going to be like way
more difficult and realized at the start
because the first time you fail at
aligning something much smarter than you
are you die and you do not get to try
again
and if we if every time we built a
poorly aligned superintelligence and it
killed us all we got to observe how it
killed us and you know not immediately
know why but like come up with theories
and come up with the theory of how you
do it differently and try it again and
build another Super intelligence than
have that kill everyone and then like oh
well I guess that didn't work either and
try again and become grizzled cynics and
tell the young guide research
researchers that it's not that easy then
in 20 years or 50 years I think we would
eventually crack it in other words I do
not think that alignment is
fundamentally harder than artificial
intelligence was in the first place
but if we needed to get artificial
intelligence correct on the first try or
die we would all definitely now be dead
that is a more difficult more lethal
form of the problem like if those people
in 1956 had needed to correctly guess
how hard AI was and like correctly
theorize how to do it on the first try
or everybody dies and nobody gets to do
any more signs and everybody will be
dead and we wouldn't get to do any more
signs that's the difficulty